masque de dark vador sabre-laser mais
aussi des tapis ou des dessous de verres
à l'effigié de la saga après une
boutique harry potter versailles a
désormais son armoire geek star wars
le magasin est situé à 5 minutes à pied
seulement du château de versailles
on s'est aperçu que il ya énormément de
fans aussi qui sont fans de l'univers de
star wars
la magie
tire sa force de l'univers donc il
fallait faire fallait oser c'est ce que
j'ai fait une boutique pour les fans de
tout âge qu'ils aient connu star wars
aux tout débuts dans les années 1970 ou
plus récemment avec la nouvelle trilogie
et les spin off les goodies viennent
pour la plupart d'angleterre des objets
qu'ils n'étaient généralement disponible
que sur internet que vous allez avoir
laissé un livre ici vous allez avoir
dark vador et un strong trooper je vais
vous faire voir une un petit produit
exclusif
la mallette métallique de han solo ici
un t-shirt exclusif par rapport à l'aîné
par rapport à anne solo donc chewbacca
rétro années 4 70 80 que ça va plaire
énormément aux dames comme à ces
messieurs
l'armorique star wars organisera
également des événements premier en date
le samedi 5 mai la boutique reçoit
lecteurs team rose qui incarne l'amiral
ackbar dans les épisodes 6 7 et 8 de la
saga